let's take a couple more if we have them
Louis we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830
4750 who's on next with me hey David Lee
Lewis is rich in Indiana rich in Indiana
what can we do for you today arm I'm I'm
so um sad to hear about Louis wanted to
go right uh having to go I just offer
from the the wisdom of Douglas Adams uh
remember to bring a towel Louis and is
that from Hitchhiker's Guide to the
volume yeah yeah and so long and thanks
for all the fish I i wanna i want to
offer please as he goes I I was how to
say I used to be real heavy and I'm real
thin and I I got real thin by addressing
issues of my thyroid function and I
recognized that I wasn't getting getting
cared for by conventional or practiced
medical information and I found stuff on
my own and it transformed my situation
and I was really cold even when I was
very heavy and it turned out that a low
functioning thyroid had anything to do
with my my comfort and also my my
disposition my damier right I'm I'm a
lot more resilient now and I'm
definitely a lot warmer and it has all
to do with what I was calling food and
addressing the issues of thyroid
function there's a class of vegetables
that are considered quite row genic
which means that they interfere with
thyroid function and I eat a lot of
vegetables but i was eating cruciferous
and brassica because of the antique
answered
diet and they turned out to be
suppressive of my thyroid function so uh
look into this idea of a difficult to
digest or just plain old hard to digest
vegetables and make sure you choose the
ones that that don't interfere with
thyroid function alright well I i had
never heard anything about this before I
never even considered my thyroid I
always just thought uh but I just wasn't
built for the cold but I will take that
into consideration you know I think that
you could uh improve or uh you know
armor up against this idea of a feeling
the cold as hard as you do well I could
be ugly old the cold thing yes I can
tell you that regardless of the
temperature in bothered I do not want to
stay in Boston I know that for sure
alright very good thank you for the call
appreciated some interesting words of
wisdom for Louis there